sind sie minderwertig oder nicht der
bundestag debattiert lebhaft über die
umstrittenen masken lieferungen von
gesundheitsminister sparen
erleichterung im klassenzimmer
mecklenburg vorpommern und sachsen
lockern die masken pflicht an schulen
und berlinale teil 2 nach der korona
online version ist nun das publikum dran
in open-air-kinos überall in der
hauptstadt
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen aber jemand ist
auch wieder dabei für den sport ein
stück von mir hoch her ging es heute im
bundestag die koalitionspartner spd und
union warfen sich gegenseitig unfaire
methoden schäbigkeit und
unaufrichtigkeit vor
hintergrund des streits das
gesundheitsministerium von cdu-minister
jens spahn wollte so der vorwurf
offenbar minderwertigere masken aus
china verteilen etwa an obdachlose oder
menschen mit behinderung
spd-arbeitsminister hubertus heil sagt
sein ministerium habe diese pläne
verhindert mehr jetzt von frank buchwald
christoph lori traute seinen augen nicht
zwar bekam der chef eines
seniorenzentrums bad kreuznach im
oktober kroner masken aus berlin
das europäische prüfsiegel aber fehlte
und die waren also lose verpackt es war
gar keine produktbeschreibung dabei und
auf der verpackung stand selbst schon on
medical also eigentlich nicht für den
medizinischen gebrauch und das ist
völlig ungewöhnlich im begleitschreiben
des gesundheitsministers hieß es dann
noch die bundesrepublik deutschland
übernehme keine haftung
offenbar kein einzelfall e-mails die dem
zdf vorliegen dokumentieren einen
längeren streit zwischen gesundheits und
sozialministerium über die qualität der
masken für bedürftige bis minister
highlight trainierte es waren
hochwertige maske verfügbar und dass man
diesen gruppen masken gibt die in vielen
bereich nicht zertifiziert oder sicher
waren
das war nicht verantwortbar und deshalb
finde ich bin ich den richtigen weg
gegangen ließ der gesundheitsminister
tatsächlich ungeeignete masken verteilen
ausgerechnet an sozial benachteiligte
dieser streit heute auch thema im
bundestag die opposition erhebt schwere
vorwürfe gegen jens spahn
sollte diese berichte zu stimmen ist der
vorgang an politischer und menschlicher
verkommenheit nicht mehr zu überbieten
und ihren aller 30
die union kontert die masken seien
geprüft und millionenfach eingesetzt
worden sie seien sicher die heftigen
angriffe gegen sparen auch vom
koalitionspartner vor allem
stimmungsmache wenn man selbst mit
parteitaktischen manövern ängste beim
menschen wird dann macht man wahlkampf
auf dem rücken der schwächeren und ich
glaube das ist eher ein skandal als
alles andere was hier angesprochen wurde
eine unabhängige untersuchung jedoch wie
sicher die maske nun tatsächlich sind
steht bisher noch aus
manchmal sind es ganz einfache dinge die
große freude bereiten das erleben gerade
schüler und lehrer in mecklenburg
vorpommern und in sachsen wegen
niedriger infektionszahlen wurde dort
die masken pflicht an schulen gelockert
zu früh finden manche expertinnen anja
cup - auf dem schulhof keine maske mehr
für die 6e der christophorusschule
rostock ist es fast wie früher nur auf
dem flur ist der mundschutz noch pflicht
im klassenzimmer kann ab die schüler
atmen auf ich finde das sehr cool weil
es ist sage ich mal auch ein bisschen
befreien dass die maske jetzt abgekommen
ist und man kann sich auch viel besser
konzentrieren wenn es wärmer wird
ich will dass man dann auch manchmal
unter der maske die testpflicht zweimal
pro woche bleibt die lehrer fast alle
geimpft endlich wieder lernen und lehren
ohne mundschutz you ja ehrlich das war
total schön
wir wussten wir schon seit gestern und
das ist eine totale erleichterung
virologin melanie brinkmann warnt
dagegen wenn wir jetzt ohne schutz und
abstand in voller klassenstärke
beschulen und auch anderswo lockern
dann nimmt die gefahr zu dass die zahl
der infektions ereignisse wieder steigt
nicht übers ziel hinausschießen so die
mahnung noch seien nicht genug menschen
in deutschland geimpft
die korona lage in deutschland entspannt
sich weiter
nur in wenigen landkreisen liegt die
inzidenz noch über 50
bundesweit registrierte das
robert-koch-institut 3254 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden
1663 weniger als vor einer woche
107 neue todesfälle kamen innerhalb
eines tages hinzu
die bundesweite incidents liegt bei 20,8
der niedrigste wert seit acht monaten
die neuinfektionen sinken aber die
wirtschaftskrise ist noch nicht vorbei
deshalb hat das kabinett die
überbrückungshilfen für firmen mit
umsatzeinbußen verlängert bis ende
september
gleiches gilt für die erleichterungen
beim kurzarbeitergeld im april 2020
waren gut sechs millionen menschen in
kurzarbeit im laufe des jahres sank die
zahl zwischenzeitlich auf gut zwei
millionen im märz 21 waren dann nach
vorläufigen daten mehr als 2,6 millionen
beschäftigte in kurzarbeit
und jetzt nach brüssel die eu kommission
startet ein verfahren gegen deutschland
wegen verletzung von eu-recht darum geht
es das bundesverfassungsgericht hatte
vor einem jahr die milliardenschweren
anleihekäufe der europäischen
zentralbank beanstandet und sich damit
über einen spruch des europäischen
gerichtshofs hinweggesetzt
aus sicht der kommission ist das ein so
wörtlich gefährlicher präzedenzfall weil
urteile des obersten gerichts für alle
staaten verbindlich sein könnte neufeld
es war ein paukenschlag das höchste
deutsche gericht widersprach dem
europäischen gerichtshof
erstmals in seiner geschichte gleicht
das bundesverfassungsgericht fest dass
handlung und entscheidungen europäische
organe offensichtlich nicht von der
europäischen kompetenzordnung gedeckt
sind und daher in deutschland keine
wirksamkeit entfalten können stein des
anstoßes die europäische zentralbank und
ihre start sein
einkäufe will ein staat sich geld leihen
bietet er staatsanleihen an
die ezb kann sie ihm nicht abkaufen denn
sie darf einzelnen staaten kein geld
geben deshalb erwerben banken die
staatsanleihen und verkaufen sie weiter
an die ezb auf diesem weg landet dann
doch noch das geld der zentralbank in
der staatskasse der europäische
gerichtshof gab dieser praxis seinen
segen das bundesverfassungsgericht aber
sah das anders so kam es zum
kompetenzstreit nach ansicht des
europäischen gerichtshofs sind die
anleihenkäufe im europarecht geregelt
deshalb sei er allein für das thema
zuständig das bundesverfassungsgericht
aber meinte die praktiken der ezb seien
von europarecht nicht gedeckt die
beteiligung deutschlands daran richtet
sich folglich nach deutschem recht
am ende könnte nur der europäische
gerichtshof in diesen kompetenzstreit
entscheiden
denn ein höheres gericht gibt es in der
eu nicht der europäische gerichtshof
würde dann über einen streit entscheiden
an dem er selbst beteiligt ist zunächst
einmal bittet brüssel jetzt die
bundesregierung um eine stellungnahme
wenn die eu-kommission damit nicht
zufrieden ist kann sie vor gericht
ziehen
anna klinik in busse warum ist die eu
bei diesem thema so streng
die eu kommission ist so streng weil es
ihm ums prinzip geht sie hält das urteil
des bundesverfassungsgerichts fans
gerade gehört für einen gefährlichen
präzedenzfall weil er weil es eben
nationales recht über eu-recht stellt
und wenn das schule machen würde so
argumentiert die eu kommission
dann wäre die durchsetzung eines
einheitlichen europäischen rechtsrahmens
in europa nicht mehr möglich die
kommission denkt dabei natürlich auch an
länder wie polen und ungarn die quasi
ständig mit eu-recht hadern und ihre
eigenen gerichte höher stellen als eu
gerichte und das urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes vor einem
jahr regelrecht gefeiert haben und
gesagt haben sieht er die deutschen
machen ist genauso wie wir unter anderem
deshalb hat die eu kommission jetzt mit
diesen blauen brief nach berlin ein
deutliches signal senden wollen
die botschaft ist
das letzte wort bei der auslegung
europäischen rechts ist haben nicht die
mitgliedstaaten der eu sondern der
europäische gerichtshof in luxemburg
live aus brüssel anne gellinek vielen
dank für diese informationen in hessen
laufen ermittlungen gegen 20 polizisten
die sich am rechtsextremen chat gruppen
beteiligt haben sollen alle beamte eines
spezialeinsatzkommandos bereits vor zwei
jahren war in einem frankfurter
polizeirevier eine chat gruppe mit
volksverhetzenden inhalten aufgedeckt
worden
susanne santina berichtet widerstehen
polizisten aus frankfurt im visier der
ermittler
und wieder geht es um rechte chat
gruppen doch diesmal sind es sogar
kräfte des spezialeinsatzkommandos sek
denen vorgeworfen wird
verfassungsfeindliche und
volksverhetzende nachrichten
ausgetauscht zu haben
der frankfurter polizeipräsident brief
heute island eine pressekonferenz ein
und betonte dass gerade an eine solche
liter einheit besondere ansprüche
gestellt werden denen sie auch gerecht
werden müssen gerade mit blick auf die
integrität und deswegen bin ich
natürlich doppelt enttäuscht dass jetzt
in diesem bereich so was auch komfort
kommt auf die spur der sek beamten kamen
die ermittler durch überregionale
ermittlungen wegen der darstellung von
kindesmissbrauch unter anderem gegen
einen mann aus rheinland pfalz der wie
sich herausstellte sek beamter in
frankfurt war und sich an den jets
beteiligt hatte innenminister peter
beuth betonte heute dass die
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen nun auch dem
letzten polizisten deutlich machen dass
jeglichem fehlverhalten konsequent
nachgegangen wird
die opposition in wiesbaden time est
eine fehlerkultur warum traut sich
eigentlich niemand auch von vorgesetzten
zu sagen da gibt es solche
rechtsextremen chats da gibt es dinge
die gerade in einer polizei nicht
geduldet werden können wir haben es mit
über 100 sogenannten einzelfällen in der
hessischen polizei zu tun mit nazi
umtrieben in der hessischen polizei
da kann man nicht erleichtert sein man
kann auch nicht von einzelfällen
sprechen
gegen alle betroffenen sek-beamten
wunsch strafrechtliche ermittlungen
eingeleitet
sie dürfen bis auf weiteres ihren dienst
nicht mehr ausüben
nach dem gescheiterten versuch die
kinderrechte in der verfassung zu
verankern kommt wohl auch eine andere
grundgesetzänderung nicht mehr zustande
das vorhaben den begriff rasse zu
ersetzen sei für diese wahlperiode durch
sagt der justiziar der unionsfraktion
es gebe keinen gesetzentwurf der
koalition die spd macht dafür die union
verantwortlich untragbare vier
rückschrittliche politik vor gleich
mehrere nachrichten heute zum thema
diesel skandal vw und der frühere
konzernchef martin winterkorn haben sich
geeinigt winterkorn zahlt 11,2 millionen
euro schadenersatz an volkswagen
insgesamt bekommt vw von mehreren
ex-managern und deren versicherungen 288
millionen euro
gegen martin winterkorn gibt es jetzt
noch eine weitere anklage und zwar von
der berliner staatsanwaltschaft
grund er soll im untersuchungsausschuss
des bundestags 2017 gelogen haben so die
behörde
drei monate vor den parlamentswahlen in
russland geht moskau immer rigoroser
gegen oppositionelle vor kreml kritische
politiker und ihre familien werden
schikaniert und bedroht und so aus dem
land getrieben christian senn hat mehr
er ist das jüngste opfer der
repressionswelle gegen die opposition
dimitri gut kopf musste russland am
sonntag verlassen
unser team trifft den ehemaligen duma
abgeordneten in der ukrainischen
hauptstadt kiew
nachdem der 41 jährige und seine familie
massiv bedroht wurden blieb ihm keine
andere wahl
man hat mich davor gewarnt dass es neue
strafverfahren gegen meine verwandten
geben werde wenn ich nicht ausreisen
alles hängt damit zusammen dass ich
nicht an den wahlen zur staatsduma
teilnehmer letzte woche waren gut kauf
und seine tante in moskau festgenommen
worden
der offizielle vorwurf mit brennerei
gut kopf berichtet von 14
hausdurchsuchungen bei ihm seinen
verwandten freunden und kollegen
nach zwei tagen u-haft durfte ihn seine
frau wieder umarmen
drei monate vor der parlamentswahl in
russland geht der kreml weiter massiv
gegen seine gegner vor
letzte woche traf es auch den ehemaligen
chef der oppositionsbewegung open roger
andré niveau war ihm drohen bis zu sechs
jahre haft
während der bekannteste oppositionelle
alex einer wahl nicht weiter im
straflager sitzt tatsächlich erleben wir
derzeit die schwerste krise der
menschenrechte und grundfreiheiten in
der modernen russischen geschichte
[Musik]
bei den wahlen werde es wieder
fälschungen geben da ist sich dimitri
gut koch sicher wann er zurück nach
russland kann weiß er nicht ich hoffe
sagt er dass sie wenigstens meine frau
und die kinder nicht drangsalieren
werden
in berlin heißt es heute vorhang auf für
die 71 berlinale zweiter teig mit einer
sommerausgabe holt das filmfestival nach
was im märz nur digital als
branchentreff möglich war
bis zum 20 juni soll jetzt auch das
breite publikum in den genuss neue filme
kommen
niedrige infektionszahlen machen es
möglich und ein besonderes konzept
gezeigt werden filme im 16
open-air-kinos verteilt über die ganze
stadt stefan nase bürger
hier finden die eröffnung und die
wichtigsten vorstellungen des
sommerfestivals der berlinale statt open
air auf der museumsinsel filmkunst in
weltkulturerbe kulisse auch vor dem
charlottenburger schloss gibt es ein
freiluftkino
insgesamt sind es 16 spielstätten
pandemie bedingt allesamt draußen
deshalb gibt es weit weniger karten für
das publikum als sonst die freude ist
trotzdem groß ich find's gut dass die
startet das wieder mehr kultur in unser
leben kommen
das was ich echt mist hab also mal auch
mal auszugehen und ins kino oder so eben
auch spontan
der politthriller der mauretanien
erzählt die wahre geschichte von mohamed
ould slahi er wurde nach den anschlägen
des 11 september von der cia entführt
und 14 jahre in guantanamo als
terrorverdächtiger zu unrecht und ohne
anklage inhaftiert
er wurde gefoltert und vergewaltigt die
menschenrechts anwältin nancy holländer
gespielt von jodie foster übernimmt den
fall
ich bin unschuldig er wurde immer wieder
verhört und man hält ihn seit sechs
jahren fest oder eine einzige anklage zu
erheben
die amerikanische rolle im krieg gegen
den terror war getrieben von rache um
diese rache zu bekommen verstießen sie
gegen das gesetz
darunter haben viele unschuldige
gelitten jodie foster hat es nicht nach
berlin geschafft aber nennt sie
holländer mit großem ziel ich hoffe dass
dieser film die debatte darüber befeuert
guantanamo endlich zu schließen und die
unbefristete haft für alle dort zu
beenden
politische anspruch eine packende
geschichte starke schauspieler ein
gelungener eröffnungsfilm und
sommerwetter das macht richtig lust auf
berliner halle im süden deutschlands war
gestern an freiluftkino nicht zu denken
wieder tobten unwetter die besonders
heftig waren weil sich die
gewitterzellen kaum vom fleck bewegt
pablo sallahi beginnt seinen bericht in
der region nürnberg eine winterliche
landschaft mittel im juni schwere
gewitter und hagel haben im fränkischen
wassertrüdingen für eine schneeweiße
schicht auf straßen und gehwegen gesorgt
mancher musste sogar die schneeschaufel
wieder herauskamen
auch andernorts demonstrierten die
naturgewalten ihre kraft in birenbach in
baden württemberg schlug ein blitz in
ein einfamilienhaus ein
mit einer wucht die bis ins erdgeschoss
reichte blitzeinschlag hat sowie die
komplette regens der 100 schlager und
satz im unteren stockwerk steckdose rand
haus gesprengt im thüringischen drei
gleichen hat starkregen straßen unter
wasser gesetzt
anwohner haben festgehalten was die
braune brühe in häusern und wohnungen
anrichtete
auch in der kommenden nacht soll es
gewitter geben wenn auch nicht ganz so
heftig wie alles nicht sooo schön zur
fußball wm norm die deutsche mannschaft
ja als ersten gegner ausgerechnet auf
weltmeister frankreich und er hatte
gestern abend seine em generalprobe
letztes vorbereitungsspiel ein wenig
glanzvoller 13 0 sieg gegen schwache
bulgaren nichts also was das deutsche
team im wm quartier in herzogenaurach
aus der ruhe bringen sollte das
trainings stadion hat heute bis auf
leichte besserung übungen noch ebenso
frei wie die mannschaft ich bin springer
die spieler probierten allerhand
ausgleichssport perthel tennis zum
beispiel da sind die füße eigentlich nur
zum laufen da was soll's noch sind es
sechs tage bis zum auftaktspiel der
deutschen mannschaft am kommenden
dienstag gegen den weltmeister die
franzosen zählen zu den top favoriten
auf den titel problem karim benzema
quält eine oberschenkelblessur seit dem
letzten test gestern gegen bulgarien
dafür bewies anton krisen man mit einem
traumtor beim 13 0 sieg die qualität der
équipe tricolore
das war kein vorbereitungsspiel ich
wollte dass wir uns schon
hineinversetzen in die bedingungen die
uns dann erwarten natürlich auf noch
höherem niveau mit dem höheren niveau
ist auch die deutsche mannschaft gemeint
die morgen um sattelt von der tat am
barren auf den frisch gesprengten rasen
so hawke in amsterdam da sind nach den
männern gestern heute auch die deutschen
hockey frauen ins halbfinale eingezogen
das dhb team setzt sich im letzten
gruppenspiel souverän mit 14 0 gegen
italien durch
vom pfosten auf den schläger von
charlotte staatenhaus springt die kugel
die diese gekonnt aufnimmt und zum 2 0
versenkt die vorentscheidung in einem
spiel das die deutschen frauen jederzeit
beherrschen hätte florschütz hatte früh
und mit gutem auge für die lücke für das
1 0 gesorgt
michael lorenz trifft nach einer
strafecke genau durch die beine der
täterin
kapitänin amelie wortmann für das
abschließende 4 zu 0 sorgt die frauen
von bundestrainer reckinger ziehen mit
zwei siegen und einem unentschieden ins
halbfinale am freitag
und da treffen wir deutschen hockey
frauen auf spanien
vielen dank girl butt wir haben noch die
lottozahlen für sie sie lauten 17 17 22
41 49 und die superzahl 3 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 5 157 die
unwettergefahr nimmt jetzt von tag zu
tag ab spätestens am wochenende wird
überall schön sagt katja oliver 14 ist
heute journal zeit mit claus kleber wir
sind morgen um 7
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren auch heute gab es
wieder zum teil kräftige gewitter
diesmal besonders betroffen die region
vom südlichen niedersachsen bis zum
alpenrand örtlich eng begrenzt kamen
wieder so 30 bis 40 liter regen pro
quadratmeter zusammen und auch jetzt am
abend gewitters noch aber die gewitter
lassen mehr und mehr nach so müssen wir
uns in der nacht höchstens noch ein aus
bayern auf gewitter einstellen sonst
geht selten noch schauer häufig ist der
himmel noch klar und es bildet sich
etwas nebel und dunst die temperaturen
sinken auf 15 bis 9 grad und morgen wird
es etwas wärmer als heute mit 22 grad an
der nordsee oder am alpenrand und bis zu
28 grad am rhein oder in der lausitz der
vormittag bringt erst mal sehr schönes
wetter sondern wolken wechseln sich ab
im süden gibt es einzelne schauer und
gewitter die wachsen sich dann am
nachmittag wieder aus zu kräftigeren
gewittern morgen liegt der schwerpunkt
zu in bayern und in sachsen und
vielleicht auch hier in baden
württemberg in den nächsten tagen geht
es weniger mit gewittern weiter es wird
immer freundlicher unschöner der sonntag
bringt dann sonnenschein bei 18 bis 27
grad für uns alle
schönen abend noch